you are watching ask doc live thank you
so much for joining us today
my name is rebecca kozak and i will be
your host for the next two
hours as we discover some
amazing empowering information on how
we can not just survive
but thrive with optimal health
now i just want to make sure everybody
knows that if you're on live with us
today raise your hand if you have
questions for dr wallach because
after he does his opening monologue
we're going to be taking questions
from the people that are here live with
us to raise your hand
in your zoom app there is a more
option and if you click on that you'll
find the raise hand
option there so please if you have
questions
raise your hand we will be going through
questions in the order that they
are raised and then back and forth
between
emails that we've received and if you
do write a comment make sure that you
include your age or the age of the
person you're inquiring about
their weight their height and not just
the one thing that you're inquiring
about but if they have any other
conditions
um dr wallick is going to need about
need to know about those as well so
this program the fda requires us to let
you know
it is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician it is for
educational information only and the
importance of nutrition and
supplementation
in a world where our food supply is
empty and void
of the nutrients that the body needs to
actually
thrive now this program will be sharing
these nutritional options
that are available through
supplementation and a form that the body
can
actually utilize it's readily
available and absorbable
this program again is not meant to take
the place of your primary care physician
the fdida requires us to let you know
that the products are not meant to treat
prevent diagnose or cure
any diseases but we bring you good news
as the genetic theory has been proven
incorrect through
science of epigenetics now epigenetics
is the study of how your behaviors and
environment can cause
changes that affect the way your genes
work
and with epigenetics you are an
empowered individual
and have more control than you think of
your own health
journey so we invite you to feel the
difference and
using the options that we will be
sharing today and to guide us
we are honored to have one of the
founding fathers of
epigenetics here to share the best
options
to obtain or maintain optimal health
dr joel wallach welcome dr wellick
and there it is epigenetics
fc genetics yes all right
thank you all right um yeah basically
uh we have wonderful bodies that we live
in
we have the capacity to
repair ourselves to reproduce ourselves
and our goal is to add 25 to 50 healthy
years everybody's life
that's why we want to share this
information because people are leaving
80 years on the table compared to what
we can have
the recorded human life expectancy is
155 years
and here in america right now our
average lifespan because of the covet
thing is 75
and so people are leaving 80 years on
the table
they're leaving 80 years on the table
they could be spending with their loved
ones and doing the things they like
whether it's fishing or golf or
playing checkers or canasta or whatever
it is
that they want to do or dance but it
takes a little bit of effort
and time investment but it's cheaper
per pound and per day than buying two
cups of starbucks coffee a day
it's it's not expensive okay and of
course you're in control
now one kind of weird piece on this
before we get into the details of the
question
um as of yesterday uh yesterday we had
121 000 new covet cases yesterday in the
united states law
121 000 new cases and is spiking
and 93 percent
of the people who are getting the
infections now
are unvaccinated 83 percent
are uh getting the uh
delta variant which came from india
and so uh and kids are starting to get
it really bad now
kids are getting it very badly and so we
need to
look at it and people say they don't
like vaccinations well that's
everybody's choice
but if you're not going to vaccinate you
have to give your immune system
everything it needs to work
efficiently to defend you that's in 215
nutrients now
as it has the core the 90 in there the
healthy start pack but the you want the
big hammer
in this case uh it's called the healthy
brain and heart pack
and when you get a vaccination people
say well why are they having all these
breakthrough infections people are
vaccinated twice they have
you know the second vaccination and then
three months later they get the bug
well that's because they didn't do all
the other stuff necessary to support
their immune system
because don't forget vaccinations do not
kill viruses bacteria fungus or yeast
bacteria just alert your body to the bad
dna and rna the bad bugs
and so when the bug appears your body
knows to attack it well if you've been
eating gluten all your life
wheat bottle rhinos your intestines are
dead you are very inefficient in
absorbing nutrients
and if you're not supplementing you're
probably only getting less than two
percent of the nutrients you need
and this is why people
even die and of course kids when they're
vaccinated
they can can and even adults from their
vaccine they can get infected
they have a lower risk of dying but they
can still get infected and infect other
people
so they still have to use our colloidal
silver they have to still use our hand
sanitizer and do
distancing and wear a mask and all this
kind of stuff we're in the middle of a
pandemic here
okay and it's not going to go away until
everybody is really working together
and doing this all right now with all
that said
uh now unless you have a wild question
about the pandemic i'm going to
go on to the to the um adding 25 to 50
healthy years your life okay
let's talk about the positive stuff dr
wallach okay
let's say 250 years 25 to 50
life loving years
but loving the days that we have oh yeah
and
and being able to do all the things you
want to do um i want everybody to be
what's called super centenarians
um we have a history of um
let's see a hundred thousand
uh hundred year olds we've had a hundred
thousand
hundred olds in the united states uh
over the last
um i know i think it's ten thousand give
me ten thousand hundred year olds for
the last hundred years and so it goes
and we've only had 32 super centenarians
and super centenarians are people who
live to be 110 and older and so
i want to have a hundred thousand super
centenarians now there are countries
that do that
there are countries that do that and you
know we brag about how good our medical
system is and all this got in the other
but when you come down to um okay well
how do you track whether the medical
system is good or not well
when you look at our professional
athletes let's look at our professional
athletes
their average lifespan of 62. and they
make a lot of money they make some of
them millions of dollars a game or an
event
their average lifespan is only 62 except
for basketball players
basketball players only live to be 51.
and why is that
that's because they're into the exercise
piece and exercise without
supplementation is the next
negative i actually have a cd out that
says the title is exercise without
supplementation of suicide okay
and um exercise on supplementation
suicide so
just that gives you a clue that there's
a problem here
with just doing extra well i eat well
and i exercise well that's not good
enough
if you want to be a super centenarian if
you want to add those 25 to 50 healthier
years your life
if you want to exercise you got to
compensate for that stay away from the
bad foods we have the good food bad food
list when they can which they can get
from you guys
and absolutely no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat by rhinos
no sugar no carbonated drinks even the
diet one's got to go
and then you need to supplement again
with the 90 which is our core thing the
healthy
start pack but i want you during this
pandemic until the pandemic is it might
be five years
before the pandemic's over and there
could be three more variants show up
in the next six months and two other
pandemics jump on us at the same time
now that happened
between 2003 and 2005. where we had h1n1
we had this the spanish flu in 1918-19
but 2003 we had h1n1 we had
sars mers we had let's see here
uh we had covet ii uh just before that
we had
polio uh we had asian flu all this kind
of stuff jumping on us all at the same
time
and that's because we went to
electricity from wood stoves
we went to electricity and that was the
cause of all this electricity was the
cause of all this
well why is that well for thousands of
years when people were using wood stoves
and fireplaces and fire pits
for cooking and light and heat they
would take the wood ashes and put them
in their gardens and wood ashes had the
minerals in it the tree had sucked up
out of the ground
and you burned the carbon but the
minerals are still there so you put the
wood ashes in the garden the carrots and
the beans and the peas and squash and
corn would suck up and what tomatoes and
peppers and all that kind of stuff would
suck up all these minerals from wood
ashes
you'd eat those things and grandma i can
remember grandma she'd put our wood
ashes we didn't have
uh electricity that was nine so we were
getting wood ashes until i was nine
and she's putting the wood ashes in our
soup and on our salads and all this kind
of stuff and i thought it was kind of
weird
but she says you take it okay whatever
grandma says you do
and um and so that's where we got it
well when we switched over to
electricity
and we didn't have any more wood ashes
and so within 10 12 years after 1882 3
o'clock in the afternoon monday
september 4th
1882 on pearl street in new york city in
the bluff overlooking the construction
of the brooklyn bridge
and that's all in the book and the cd
called hell's kitchen it goes into the
history of all these pandemics
and when we switched to electricity it
was a big problem
all the industrialized nations switched
electricity and so they all got all
these diseases at the same time
30 40 50 new diseases and doctors this
was the beginning of the darling of
genetics
and says well these are all just new
genetic diseases we've never really paid
attention to before they're a genetic
thing
no they were just nutritional
deficiencies and so
when we came out with our cd in 2003 in
our in the book
hell's kitchen 2005 and
we came out with the um healthy brain
and heart pack which has 215 nutrients
including that 90 and
we were able to take people who had all
these terrible
genetic diseases in two or three days
they were gone
because we're giving them the nutrients
the body needed to prevent these
symptoms
so that's kind of the good news i think
we have a lot of experience we've got it
published
and um diet is a big thing
you cannot eat well enough to get
everything you need i'll repeat that you
cannot eat well enough to get everything
you need
you must supplement and if you do
supplement
you're going to be very very happy but
you do have to stay away from the bad
stuff
maximize absorption now um
let's see here let's look at some of the
ages let's look at some of the oldest
ones
excuse me let's look at um
china they actually their average
lifespan in china is only 74.
our enzyme span is 75. so they leave 81
years on the table
you go to hunza which is the honza cuts
that lived between pakistan and china
they lived near the gilltard glacier
they were the subject of james hilton's
book
and movie called lost horizon talked
about shangri-la and everybody thinks
that's a mythical place shangri-la is a
mythical place no
it's actually a valley in hunza
these people lived to be an average of
um
uh let's see here 120 delivered be an
average of 120
but the oldest ones lived to be 165 168
but the ones that they really tracked
and james hilton was a very vicious
investigative reporter for the new york
times and london times and there was
this
chinese doctor by the name of chi um
when
uh
oh shoot me no dr lee chen yuan there
you go dr lee chenyun
and uh he was running around selling
herbs saying he was 265
and that uh you know you buy his herbs
you can live a long time too
and so they sent to james hilton there
and he found this guy for a year
and took his fingerprints on things that
he touched after he leave to get the
fingerprints and check it from some
place 50 years ago he was supposed to be
those those are his fingerprints
and so he wrote a big article from the
front page of the new york times in 1929
and it was so well received also for the
london times
he wrote a book on it called lost her
eyes and people loved the book so much
it was a bestseller
he helped produce a movie out of
hollywood
called lost horizon 1933
uh also won all kinds of awards for that
but everybody thought that was all
mythical stuff no
it was actually the truth now let's look
at a couple more here
let's look at um
well the hunters are only leaving on the
average they're only 120
subtracted from 155 they're only leaving
35 years on the table when you look at
the long-lived ones
they're a positive they're living 10 15
20 years longer
than 155. okay so that's doable
but you have to be on top of it and so i
think
uh let's see here
okay latinos the united states they tend
to live the longest
in the united states 81.8 and so they're
only leaving 73 years on the table
uh black americans uh only lived with
72 so subtract that from 155 they're
leaving 83 years on the table
and here's the big one are you ready for
this the big one
medical doctors especially in the
emergency room their average lifespan is
only 57.
they're leaving 98 years on the table
medical doctors are not the people to
ask for longevity now you get run over
by a truck you need to go to the
emergency room
right you have some massive infection
pushes coming out of your eyes
everything you need to go get some
antibiotics but that's
that's very telling when the average
life is cdc center for disease control
published this information about three
months ago
that's where i got the information from
center for disease control the
government agency not me i didn't figure
that out
they published it front pages on the
newspapers there's lifespan of emergency
room doctors is 57 they're leaving 98
years on the table
so um we want to look to the hunsas
and this is why we really got into what
we do
get rid of the bad stuff take all the
known nutrients that your immune system
requires
what every cell in your body requires to
maximize its lifespan maintain itself
repair itself replace itself when it
dies from old age
and we can actually add 25 to 50 health
for years our life
my goal is in my lifetime and i'm 82
years old i expect to live to be at
least 110
at least is a hundred percent super
centenary i want to see some super
centenarians
that you know came in with us when they
were 50 60 70 years old
i've been doing this for 50 years so
it's possible that some of the people
we've been working with for 50 years
could be super centenarians
here pretty quickly
absolutely absolutely they can dr
wallach
i i know we have people that
have been with you at least 25 years
they're in their 90s now
and still kicking around as if they were
in their 50s 60s yeah they're still
playing golf and playing tennis and
walking for a couple of miles around
with their great-great-grandkids and all
kinds of stuff and
um it's it's one of those things where
it's a blessing you know you look back
in the biblical days and people are very
skeptical you know
moses lived to be 300 and methuselah
would be 969.
well what if that was true wouldn't you
want to know what they did
of course absolutely absolutely
well i just want to let everybody know
that you can find the good foods bad
foods list that dr wallach mentioned
on our website at askdoclive.com
there's even a little spot there that
you can sign up and have it
emailed to your email address so
all of the information that you are
hearing about today
you can find the replay of today's
program
also at askdoclive.com
and dr wellick is going to be going
through
some some protocols as we're answering
questions
and all of the products that he mentions
today can be found in the store but i
want to make sure that
everybody is very clear if somebody
invited you to watch
this program don't go to our store
get back with the person that invited
you to this program
they have an interest in making sure
that you get exactly what you need and
they may have a special way of ordering
and you want to give them the courtesy
because they thought enough of you
to invite you to this program so please
get back with them
now if nobody specifically invited you
to this program
on our website we have a contact us
option where you can send us an email
with your specific
questions that i will be going through
some and we get a lot but i'll be going
through some today with dr wallach and
getting some
answers for our listeners
and we greatly appreciate all of you
for being here with us we welcome you
to invite your friends
you know this is information that can
um help people change the trajectory
give them a pivot point from going from
bad health
to looking at brighter future
so please share this program with others
invite them to the askdoclive.com
website so that they can sign up to
receive their own reminders
and newsletter about information that we
share through
our program i cannot forget
our amazing co-hosts we've got jonty
mccollier who is running
all of the technical stuff that we
greatly greatly appreciate
we have the beautiful nasima omar who is
putting
comments in the chat and the beautiful
ruth ellen sanchez who is as well
and making sure that everything runs
smoothly i could not do this without
them
so i have a heartfelt thanks for all of
and that for dr wallach for who takes
two hours of his time
every friday to be here with us and make
this an opportunity where we can get
information from the man himself
so dr wallach i have
mike has a question here in the comments
and i don't know if it's something that
you're
um able to comment on or something that
you want to look into
but he wants to know if you can comment
on graphene
oxide which is in the vaccine that
they're trying to mandate
okay i'll do some research on that but i
don't want to come on it now
because i don't know enough about it
thank you so much that's what i kind of
figured
and i greatly appreciate that you're
taking the time to look into it
so let's go to our first hand that is up
and that is marianna's paint marianna go
ahead and unmute yourself
you are on
there you go you are on live with dr
wallace oh wait
let's try to unmute you again
okay so i just did a request to unmute
all you have to do is say okay
oh okay okay um i have my cat
on the supplements you recommend it but
i just wondered
what food do you want should i be giving
her because
i don't know if she should have the
kidney diet that would have gluten in
it okay no you don't want the kidney
diet that has gluten in it no
basically you want to get a good grade
of canned or dry dog food or i like to
use a mix a half and half after i
have a cat food half dry half canned
cat food and just read the label six
times to make sure there's no wheat
brother eye oats in it
and the beautiful thing about these
commercial diets for cats and dogs is
they put a lot of vitamins and minerals
in there
but i also want you to add the arthrodex
it's one scoop for 20 pounds of body
weight so the cat weighs six eight
pounds give it a half a scoop of the
arthrodex
don't forget the efas and cats
particularly like our efa pluses which
come from
fish liver and so they like that because
they like the fishy taste
i'm giving her both those okay good
and i'm giving her the fatty acids
the yeah the the f8 pluses yes and the
and the super kb okay that's fine
excellent but but it's okay to just to
give a regular cat food as long as it's
gluten free that's correct okay
and that saves you a lot of effort it's
consistent and
and so you know they've done a lot of
research they have a lot of vitamins and
minerals in there
and so it's it's pretty high quality
stuff
people living under the bridge human
beings who live under the bridge who eat
cat food and dog food live longer than
medical doctors who live to be 57.
oh that's interesting
all right thank you so much marianna and
best wishes on your kitty
thank you dr wellick as you you started
out
in the animal world well after fixing
yourself
but your your research around the world
and all that you did with mutual omaha
and all of their funding um
it's just incredible it was inspiring i
watched it as a kid
so now and the world wildlife fund
yes yes so i
i loved i loved watching your work as a
kid and i know that
there's many on here who also did and to
be
to have you here live is is such a great
honor
thank you let's go to our next hand
and rose uh oh rose doesn't have her
audio connected
so let's go to christy christie
go ahead and unmute yourself you're
online with dr wallach
okay can you hear yes ma'am okay
i'm 71 5'2 111 pounds
and i have macular cellophane
macular pucker and i was wondering
if what you would recommend for that or
if there is anything okay are you
completely blind are you wearing glasses
or what
no actually on the macular cellophane
it's just on my right eye and it's like
i am looking through cellophane
okay now let me ask you a couple of
quick questions here do you have any
tinnitus any ringing in the ears
yes i had sudden i had sudden hearing
loss
in 2004 on my right on my right ear
of course same side yes
okay and so do you have any balance
issues
vertigo balance on and off yes
okay all right uh let's see here you
have a little bit of white and gray here
do you have any varicose veins well my
my hair is actually kind of a light
brown during the summer i spray it with
a lightener
but where it's gray is just over my
left ear it doesn't matter if you have
one gray hair that answers my question
yes you have great yes it's not an aging
thing it's a
nutritional deficiency that gives you
great white and silver here that's what
i'm asking
now do you also have any varicose veins
no just a few little spider veins
okay well the spider veins are baby
varicose veins
okay okay they're caused by the same
thing it causes the white gray silver
hair
and of course uh you can get um let's
see here vitiligo you get skin color
loss
uh and you can get aneurysms in your
brain and aorta and die from those
from that same deficiency one deficiency
causes all those different diseases
and symptoms now you have osteoporosis
of the skulls what's your problem
did your doctor tell you hit
osteoporosis and skull
actually i don't go to doctors because
i'm retired from the i won't say i'll
say medical field and i've seen
too many yeah okay question one quick
question
okay good question do you have any other
issues any hubble pressure diabetes or
arthritis or sciatica or anything like
that
i've had sciatica since like 1993.
okay okay well sciatic is a back problem
squeezing the sciatic nerves you get
stuff going down your legs and maybe
even hammer toes
and tingling numbness and pain your feet
and ankles and that kind of stuff
do you have anything going on in your
hands and wrists anything going on your
hands and wrists and fingers
sugar finger or anything like that no
okay um have you lost your sense of
smell or taste
no all right well you have o n a
o n a o n a is a abbreviation for optic
nerve atrophy when you have osteoporosis
of the skull it squeezes the eighth
cranial nerve which causes the tinnitus
the rain in the ear
balance problems and also
uh let's see here uh uh
cause uh let's see here i said the
vertigo can also cause ona optic nerve
atrophy it squeezes the optic nerve the
optic artery going into the eye and the
optic vein coming back out of the eye
i've won so many best with eye doctors i
said i can reverse that very quickly and
they said
no you're a gd liar wallet and i had a
bet with them
the one guy who he gave me 27 charts and
he couldn't argue
because he those were his patient he
picked them they were legally blind six
eight ten years
and in 90 days you could all read 20 20
without glasses on my program i'm going
to give you here
so pay attention you got to get rid of
all the bad foods
absolutely no fried foods no processed
smears no oils no glutens no wheat no
butter in oats no sugar no carbonated
drinks either that one's got to go
and then at um let's see here you said
you weighed 111 pounds
i want you to get one healthy brain and
heart pack per month but i want you to
get another bottle of our slam not
not from the grocery store not from the
pharmacy
not from walgreens but i want you to get
our extra slime one bottle of our slime
comes with the health advantage heart
pack but once you take three twice a day
or two three times a day for a total of
six a day of our selenium
there's five cofactors in our selenium
no other no other saline on the market
has these cofactors
these cofactors when you're deficient in
them
you get vitiligo you get spider veins
you get varicose veins you get gray hair
you get sciatica you get osteoporosis of
the skull
you got all of them did you ever get any
hiccups or copd
no okay good all right
so uh again i want you to have one
healthy branded heart pack and another
bottom of the sleeves and take three of
those twice today
the brain healthy brain and heart pack
wants to take a half a dose of
everything at breakfast have it does for
each other time there's i don't know
eight or ten different products in there
and then i also once you get our msm get
one polymer msm thing take three twice a
day it's a big problem you can do that
with one bottle
and they will support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
the vertebrae bone makes your bone
itself
that'll help you get rid of the the um
osteoporosis of the skull and all of
these
various things that are caused by this
we actually have a book out it's called
it's all in your head you might want to
get
the book so you can read the details
uh okay good and then
um let's see here um the sciatica
will go away within 90 days i don't care
if you've had it for 40 50 years
you'll rebuild your disc with that it'll
go away i also want you to have three of
our
um let's see here three of our vitamin
d3 capsules twice a day has two bottles
a month
i want you to have um
our glucogen twice a day take um three
capsules twice a day it'd be one bottle
a month
uh if you prefer the liquid you can get
one quart a month and take a half an
ounce of breakfast half an ounce of
dinner time
and then i would also throw in
the um let's see here few coins z
capsules take three twice a day support
your immune system and anti-inflammatory
it has eight or nine different seaweeds
from an ocean and it's really really
great stuff
so if you want something to drink we
have camp coffee we have robust coffee
we have decaf coffee
we have a rebound or sports drink with a
hundred nutrients in it
comes in little paper sticks uh 30 in a
box or it comes in cans
and so these are the sort of things you
want to do and call us every two weeks
because
your age years for that age where people
between
ages of 40 and and 75
get all these things and doctors tell
them look you're this is your age
you're bound to get these things they're
needed yeah that's absolutely not true
these are not aging they're all
nutritional deficiency diseases which
you can reverse very quickly 90 days you
should all be gone
what about what about antibac
vision fx okay
okay well that well that's why i wanted
you to throw in that's what i wanted to
throw in
the a few coins z take three of those
twice a day but if you want to take the
occutiv
there's no i don't think there's an a on
the end um unless they've added it
recently
if you're right okay okay i started that
i've only been on it about a week so
okay yeah so you can go ahead and take
one twice a day every two hours a month
because i come 30 in a bottle
i do that i take one twice a day and i
take the vision fx i take three of those
twice a day
i didn't want to load you up with too
much but it will give
the eye you know more nutrition so it
can heal faster
but again i've taken these people who
were diagnosed
for six eight 10 12 years being totally
blind
as having max degeneration and glaucoma
and
cataracts all this kind of stuff it was
really just on a optic nerve atrophy
and so and so the doctors had to pay off
they paid off big time because they had
to pay for all the supplements for all
their
patients that you know those 12 patients
um
and they had to pay me some stuff
including a very expensive bottle of red
wine from france
okay so you'll have a great time with
this because um
as you you know when you go back to your
doctor if you go to a doctor you said
you didn't go to doctors
but if you do ever go to a doctor the
one who diagnosed you
with well i did i did go to an
optometrist and i have an
appointment with a retinal specialist
next week okay
okay well give me 90 days yeah yeah well
of course he's got kids in college and
tuition is due
of course okay so um
but don't don't don't agree to any
surgery until give me 90 days
okay good all righty okay
okay christy right yes okay god bless
you very much
thank you christy so dr wellick you had
mentioned something about
um true finger we have a question
said that was associated with
osteoporosis of the skull correct
i'm sorry i missed you you were kind of
buzzing there trigger finger
oh trigger finger yeah that's obviously
your process of the skull and don't
say oh syndrome and all that kind of
stuff
but it's like hammered toes when you
have osteoporosis
of the back you have sciatica squeezing
the sciatic nerves
and you get all this pain down in your
feet and you put something on your feet
and nothing happens
you gotta use our cm cream our trauma
oil and our soothe on your back
for temporary pain relief and the pain
in the feet will go away
same thing put all the stuff on your
shoulders and your neck
in the back your skull and all the stuff
in your hands go away
awesome so let's talk about the pain in
the feet because
um urel wrote in and
said what can i do to get rid of
neuropathy i don't know
um he says when i walk it feels like i'm
walking on gravel with
swollen feet okay well neuropathy
in the feet of course is caused by
sciatica so it's the back thing
they may shrink an inch or two vertebrae
get closer
to smash the nerves they may just have
osteoporosis of the vertebrae
straight and um also squeezing the
sciatic nerves
and this causes peripheral neuropathy
it's the same thing
they say oh man when i lay down at night
it's terrible because that position
squeezes those nerves more than when
you're standing up straight
or sitting with a vertical back
the neuropathy is one of the easiest
things to get rid of because it's very
simple nutritional deficiencies
and again health abandoned heart pack
one per hundred pounds of body weight
msm uh three twice a day per hundred
pounds of body weight
vitamin d3 glucogen wouldn't hurt to
throw in
the collagen peptides a dose of that
powder
in the middle of the day because it has
collagen from four different classes of
animals
there's fish and poultry and sheep and
beef and so we're very very proud of
that one
uh it very quickly helps with the
neuropathy but you have to take out
everything else
everybody wants to say well can i just
take an aspirin or can i just take one
pill
no um this is a very complicated thing
you've got like um 18 things going on
there
and every one of those 18 things needs
90 essential nutrients
so you know you just can't that's why we
came up with these packages
because we didn't want people to have to
sit there and figure out exactly
everything they needed but we do have
what we call secret sauces let's say you
have
and many people do let's say they have
20 different diseases you know they've
got diabetes and high pressure and
they've got peripheral neuropathies
they've got atrial fibrillation
tachycardia they've got hiccups
they got asthma um they got ringing in
their ears they're losing their vision
they have ibs irritable bowel syndrome
and they have gastroparesis pain in
their stomach
all this stuff it takes a different set
of nutrients for every one of those but
they all need the 90.
so you have to take the 90 and then a
secret sauce for each one of these
and that's why we came out with that
package called um
the trilogy books will announce the
quartet of books let's play doctor let's
pay herbal doctor passport growing
therapy and it's all on your head
those four books will cover 600
different diseases
tell you what to do pharma yeah so dr
wallick i found
out that it's all up in your head is
sold out on amazon
so i want to make sure everybody knows
that you can go to
dr wallach.com
and you will find dr wallach's
books there as well so d is it dr j
drj yeah dot
com and that'll be coming right from his
his warehouse so it's exciting that it's
sold out on amazon
oh yeah let's see uh yeah it's because
amazon gets so many calls
about that book and so of course they
they
uh they're not printing it they have to
come to us to get to fulfill their
orders so we're happy to do that and
it's very good
get it out there save as many as we can
absolutely
all right so marianne put a put a
question in the comments here
um in regards to a male 74 years old
5 foot 10 inches a1c is
5.6 bp is
122 over 68. the prostate has gradually
enlarged restricting
urine stream what should he take to
reduce the prostate
okay see i would ask him does he have
sciatica does he have any back problems
because 99 of the time when the doctor
says oh you have a prostate problem
they really have a back problem
squeezing the sciatic nerves to control
the bladder
because when a woman has urinary
problems they can't say she got a
prostate problem
okay and so
you always have to ask do you see his
blood
sugar is under control so i'm assuming
he's got diabetes he's taken medication
a1c 5.6 is good um
122 over 68. i think my blood pressure
is like 68 over 40
and i'm 82 years old
and that's because i take all my
supplements and i walk two miles a day
do 20 push-ups twice a day
and you know i could probably take on
five guys by myself right now
it's uh you know i did it many times in
my life i was in the military 27 years
so um uh what we're gonna do for this
guy is get him off all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens
then i want him to um
because he's 122 pounds i'm going to
have one healthy brain at heart
per month get another bottle of the
selenium so i can take three twice a day
i'm gonna get one bottle of msm so i can
take three of those twice a day
i want him to get the vitamin d3 three
of those twice a day two bowels a month
and then the collagen i want to take um
let's see here glucogel five of those
twice is two bottles a month
and because he had probably has a blood
sugar problem do not cold turkey off the
medication
but get him on two bottles a month of
our sweeties so take three of those
twice a day
and as he's testing his blood sugar on a
daily basis or three times a week
as his blood sugar is coming down he can
slowly reduce his medication
based on the numbers as he's been taught
to do and usually we take people
that have been on medication for
diabetes for 20 25 30 years
and in two weeks time they're able to
reduce their medication by 50
and another two weeks are totally off
the medication because type 2 diabetes
which makes up 98 of the diabetic
population is um
a very similar nutritional deficiency
now bouncing back to the
prostate in addition to all these things
which is going to help the back
which is i think what's going on with
this guy's quote prostate unquote
but if he also wants to take something
from the prostate which i do i take
three of our prostaff x capsules twice a
day that's two vowels a month
and it gives very specific nutrients
that the prostate requires to do its
function and so you're kind of covering
both bases there
awesome thank you so much dr wallach
let's go to our next hand up
carol cheryl go ahead and unmute
yourself
you're on live with dr wallach hey um
can you hear me okay yes ma'am okay
uh the gal before i think answered some
of my questions
i it sounds like i do have the
osteoporosis of the skull
on the symptoms that you were describing
um
but i was wondering is it like a one
size fits all
i'm about the same age well i'm 72
i'm five foot and i'm 145.
um so i'm happy i'm 40 pounds
about 40 pounds overweight i thought i
was
25. that's
but anyway is it kind of uh um
the the packs that you were mentioning
it it went by too fast for me i'm gonna
have to listen to the recording so i can
write these down
if i get the spelling right i guess but
anyway
um is it like a one size fits all i'm
quite a bit what
what goes by body weight and so no i
would just take exactly the same thing
even though you're a few pounds more
than her i would just go with the same
thing stay away from the same bad foods
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no glutens no wheat bar i know no
sugar
uh no carbonated drinks and um
you will be a miracle uh like i say in
in two to four weeks you're gonna see
magic in six to eight weeks is it could
be everything can be totally gone
but certainly within 90 days you'll be a
new woman now to lose weight i also have
i also have um high blood pressure that
i take medication
before probably because of my weight but
okay well no
no no okay do you have a kid do you have
a kidney issue
no okay well you may have you don't know
it yet
the kidney releases a hormone called
renin which drives your blood pressure
up
and so what i want you to do is get our
ultimate daily classic tablets to add to
your program
ultimate daily classic tablets take
three twice a day
and i take people that haven't urinated
in 10 years or on dialysis six times
six times a week and then in two weeks
time they're on dialysis
only three times a week because they've
started urinating again after 10 years
and then after two more weeks they're
totally off a dialysis which they've
been on for 25 years because they didn't
want to get a kidney transplant
i do this thousands of times a month all
over the world
um this is very very easy to deal with
kidney issues and blood pressure
and so your blood pressure will be
the healthy um let's see here
the ultimate daily classic tail is will
support healthy blood pressure and
healthy blood flow through
the blocked arteries you have blocked
arteries in your kidneys
maybe your brain coronary arteries and
you're kind of like a savings account
for the doctor
okay he's gonna say yeah well let's just
keep an eye on this you know we may have
to do
a coronary bypass we may have to do put
some stents in
all that kind of stuff because you know
when
college tuition is due that's when you
need the operation
[Laughter]
and so um by doing these things we've
just said the diet plus the supplement
program
all this goes away because of
nutritional deficiency diseases
interesting well i did have a stroke
about three years ago
okay now what well now wait a minute
what type of stroke was it was it
was it a blood clot or is it a
hemorrhage it was
through high blood pressure i've always
had high cholesterol
and i thought oh boy caught up with me
they put me in the hospital overnight
ran all kinds of tests mri on my head
they uh did the heart and everything and
my veins were clean
but i've always had high cholesterol
okay well cholesterol does well
cholesterol does not cause
blocked arteries that was a lie and that
was yeah
but they but i did not have blocked
arteries they said do they
did you put did you put your
understanding drugs they still
wanted to put me on um don't do it
no no no i tried the lipitor but we we
do hiking a lot and i noticed
all my joints were getting all i
couldn't move
very well i didn't realize it was the
lipitor
yeah and well stand drugs stand drugs
will actually cause alzheimer's disease
well i i took it for like a week and
then got off lipitor i was fine all my
joints were back to normal
okay good okay okay
okay rebecca how are you doing here all
right
so thank you so much carol and i hope
i'm pronouncing that right
uh yes yes it's just carol awesome
oh okay so dr wally
the next actually the next person
actually wrote in
and was my first email or my next email
that i was going to go to so julie
go ahead and unmute yourself
hello emily you are
live with dr walla julie great hi
hi um i have i was diagnosed with
pulmonary
arterial hypertension about six months
ago
and um i've been in and out of the
hospital
i'm very emotional right now because
it's been very hard for me
um i have had a lot of fluid in my lungs
i'm 62 years old
i'm 5 foot 2 inches tall i weigh about
and it fluctuates because of the fluid
on my body a lot
um i go ahead okay do you have any
highlight pressure or diabetes
no i don't know i have any diabetes i
have asthma
and that's about i did have high blood
pressure
before years ago but my blood pressure
is always really low now
i don't know if that means i have to
love it or what okay let's stop there a
minute
okay um do you have any uh skin problems
any eczema dermatitis or psoriasis
i'm starting to get that i noticed a
little bit yeah
okay well that's the nutritional
deficiency caused by gluten
okay blocking your intestines you can't
absorb it so you need to get off of
gluten no wheat no water on oats
you can't have oatmeal for breakfast you
can't have any um fried foods of any
kind
okay you you cannot have any breakfast
champions no
no waffles no pancakes no spaghetti
factory none of that got no flour
tortillas
okay if you're going to drink beer it's
got to be rice beer from australia
i don't know okay good all right
and so there you go um because all these
things you have
do you have any bowel problems any
irritable bowel syndrome constipation
i have constipation and diarrhea off and
on
and it's uh my it's not been regular for
months
okay so probably ibs or crohn's disease
or something like that celiac disease
one
you know one of those so these you have
a very severe gluten problem
all of these are caused by gluten gluten
alert gluten alert you don't work in a
you don't work in a bakery do you
no do you work in a restaurant no i
don't
do you cook for a lot of people no
okay you need to stay away from gluten
don't even say the word
okay i will do that okay then
at 135 pounds i want you to take
two healthy brain and heart packs per
month they have all the nutrients in
there
this is going to help you with your
asthma your bowel problems
your skin issues also your
your pulmonary issues um this can be do
you have any tinnitus or ringing in the
ears or balance problems
i don't have any tinnitus but i'm always
short of breath and i'm always
about ready to pass out okay that could
be copd and they're calling it asthma
but it could be copd do you ever get
hiccups
no okay good uh do you have any back
problems any sciatica anything in your
legs or arms
i have uh some back problems i kind of
attribute that to
having not having a really good mattress
or whatever but
it's just no it's all no it's all
attribute to that gluten you're not
absorbing nutrition
okay okay here we go again none of the
bad foods i want to take two healthy
brain and heart pattern month to full
dose everything twice a day
i want you to get two bottles a month of
our msm so you can take three with each
meal is nine a day three with breakfast
through the lunch
dinner time and they're gonna support
and promote maintenance repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between the vertebrae bone
makes your bone itself skull
skin bowel the walls of the bowels which
have a lot of connective tissue in it
the walls of arteries and veins you have
gray hair you're coloring your hair
no i don't color my hair and i have
maybe
just a few up there but i do have a few
okay
the answer is yes okay do you have any
varicose veins or spider veins
uh-huh yes okay well there you go and so
yeah and so then i want you to also have
let's see i said the two vowels of msm i
want you to take vitamin d3 three of
those twice today
msm and three is going to be three of
the vitamin
d3 twice today two bottles a month once
you get two bottles a month of the
of the glucogel so you can take five
twice a day that'd be five capsules
twice
a day and then for um something
um you want to to drink we do have our
rebounder sports drink with a hundred
nutrients in it
okay you don't wanna be drinking diet
cola but if you want to have
um caffeine free coffee or robust coffee
we have those our java fit coffees
all the we own the plantations we
fertilize the bushes with all our
minerals and things
and so call us every two weeks because
you are going to help a lot of people
uh just getting rid of the bad foods
you're going to lose the weight
you need to lose i don't think you need
to lose much at five to 135 pounds
you're about right
but all these issues you have are all
due to gluten
every one of them and so you you're
going to see magic
in two weeks and six weeks eight weeks
and ten weeks you're you're going to see
magic here
and i i really hope so i've been
watching
i've been listening to you on coast to
coast forever and i've been i'm so happy
to be able to talk to you
um okay julie well thank you where
you're gonna be a star
because you're gonna your stories your
testimonies will be very good help a lot
of people
if you you know if you happen to need to
go to the doctor it's a regular
appointment or whatever
uh he he might i have people tell me my
doctor said
this all this lab work can't be right
because they had all these problems for
20 years and now they're some of them
are gone and some are 50 percent better
he said i probably got somebody else's
stuff so he redid the test it came back
the same
and he didn't ask me what i was doing he
just says keep doing what you're doing
the doctors never want to know what
you're doing
right um i have one more question
i have got my doctor my pulmonologist
has got me on
a drug uh inhaler it's called divaso
i'm on to dalathol furosemide all this
stuff and i'm wondering
when i mean i'd like to not have to take
all that
okay what you want to do okay what you
do you essentially have a respiratory
problem you want to take continue taking
your respiratory medication
okay and and say well i'm feeling pretty
good here
and so i'm gonna reduce my medication by
okay it might take you two weeks and
then after another two weeks you know
i'll reduce another 10
don't just cold turkey off of it right
okay that's what i
kind of figured all right sounds good
thank you so much well thank you
awesome thank you julie i'm glad you
were able to get on and talk to doc
yourself that's fabulous
so i want to remind everybody because i
when i'm dealing with people i'm not
dealing with them when i'm able and
honored to be able to work individually
with people um
they're always like there's gluten in
everything that's impossible
well dr wallick actually
chef norman has put out a cook
book that features dr
wallach's way of eating and cooking
so i want to encourage everybody to
go out and it's on amazon you can
actually find it on our website
dr wallach's holding up the be d book
there
wallick d r generalic.com there
as well um and also on the askdoc
live.com under the books and it's dr
walt's
cooking with the good and bad foods
cookbook cooking
cooking without the bad foods oh without
without the bad foods
sorry it keeps going back and forth so i
don't see it there
okay okay let me let me read you a
paragraph
this was a three year study by three
three tv
chefs in eastern canada you know they
were really onto my neck because i'm
saying don't eat gluten don't eat oils
don't do this don't do that
and they got on me and it's okay well
like you know this can't be right people
been eating this way for thousands of
years
that's why we're in trouble this is not
correct
and so it's okay let's do a study here
so i said hey i'm
in and so what we did for three years
was in eastern canada
they got a questionnaire and these guys
you know are tv chefs and they also
worked in big restaurants and hotels and
things and so
they put these questionnaires out in
restaurants
and people had their choice where they
wanted to take our foods or the regular
ones
and so this is what this chef said chef
norman
he was the chief of these three chefs
here
three year study i have worked with the
culinary industry for well over 20 years
when i first encountered dr wallach's
food recommendations i believe it was
impossible to cook that way
in the food industry oil and gluten are
ubiquitous and everybody loves it
fortunately i was wrong fortunately i
was wrong and in the last two years we
have
recreated every dish i can think of
without the forbidden ingredients
we have gone back to the basics of
cooking and we have fit dr wallach's
recommendations into all of the methods
i was taught in chef school
i've done my best to include as many
variations of traditional recipes
so this book should be able to feed a
family a huge variety of healthy food
that also tastes good and retains
the qualities of taste and texture you
love now
this book is 300 pages of recipes
300 pages of recipes okay
and again dr wallick's
cooking without the bad foods okay
and um uh chef um
norman he was the chief of the three
chef chef norman
uh and organized all this because the
three of them you know they're
high-fiving and didn't believe me and
they were going to just beat me up and
they came along well i'm glad they did
because i always have people asking if
there's a cookbook
is there is that'll help me and now
there is
now pamela just put up a question dr
while she says she knows that there's no
oil does that include solid coconut oil
and if dairy intolerant is coconut
milk okay no because coconut milk
has a little bit of the oil in it okay
it's not just
coconut water it has a little bit of the
oil in it and
uh you know if you're gonna eat eat some
coconut you just want to eat the coconut
meat
and then you better be taking lots of
antioxidants take extra selenium that
day and so forth
but um our efas and efa pluses
are extracted our efas are extracted
from seeds or apa plus extracted from
fish livers
we do this in a room that's filled with
nitrogen everybody has to you know be in
scuba outfit
okay and so then they're put into soft
uh capsules that are flushed with
nitrogen before you put the oils in them
they're sealed then the bottles are
flush with nitrogen before we put those
capsules in there
and it's sealed and then we put the top
on and seal it again
so our stuff efas and fa pluses can be
on a shelf
for a year and they're not going to
oxidize because they're in a nitrogen
in a nitrogen and a nitrogen nitrogen
filled bottle
and the capsules and stuff and so this
is
very important uh this is one of the
things we went out of our way nobody has
gone to that extreme
to make sure that there's no oxidation
of our
their essential nutrients for essential
nutrients and people say well what about
olive oil
well you want to kill yourself go ahead
and eat olive oil
if you want olive oil just go to the
tree pick the olive off if it needed
but you can't have olive oil just olive
oil in a
bottle sitting on your kitchen table
every day at room temperature
it's going to kill you because it
oxidizes and turns into trans fats
heterozygotes acrylamides which cause
cancer and all kinds of inflammation
yeah so any of these things that are
taken out of their natural
existence and they're exposed to oxygen
look at the word oxidation ox right
there
and it's exposed to oxygen it's going to
start oxidizing so we want to
take that out of our diet well i've got
another big story now i'm going to give
it to you now because we're copyrighting
it
okay um this big story uh
had part of it's about oxidation and um
i'm just going to stop there i'll just
say this is a big story come out so we
are um
uh copyrighting it so nobody can steal
it now the reason i'm copyrighting it
when i came up with a cause for instant
cure of cysticerosis
and told them it wasn't a genetic thing
at the yarkees primary center i was
working for nasa they fired me because
like you're nuts everybody knows this is
a genetic thing and then
um we gave jerry lewis a bunch of our um
uh charts of kids that marvin rob and i
were working with the amish community
that had much reason which we're going
to talk about in the next hour monster
history
and we're curing them right left and
center and um
we gave it to jerry lewis he checked it
out with the doctors who confirmed that
they were no longer muslim patients
he jerry lewis was so excited after 20
years of the telethon he took it to the
monstrosity association and they fired
jerry lewis
and so and you haven't heard anything
but about the telethon and jerry lewis
since they fired him
and so the mississippi association um we
actually
forced through federal courts that these
baby formulas put these nutrients
in the baby farmers infamil similac we
won
april 16 2013 and so
this is a federal court issued demand on
these
manufacturers we ended cystic fibrosis
we ended monstrosity
and as a side benefit we ended sentiment
death syndrome mothers were not laying
on their babies it was simple
nutritional deficiency disease
and um doctors didn't know it so they
blamed it on the mothers
right well takes that
that feeling of guilt that it is not the
mother's fault
no the mother the mothers are not laying
on the babies the babies are dying of
hypertrophy cardiomyopathy heart disease
it's the same thing dr milan and i we
went to china we did one thousand
seven hundred autopsies on kids under
the age of ten
one thousand seven hundred autonomous
that's why the federal court ruled in
our favor because they couldn't go
against it was published in three
languages
yeah wow um so one more question
because we are at the top of the hour
pamela wanted to know about
using key for for probiotics
so i know kiefer can be either a water
kefir or
a melt kefir so i'm thinking maybe she's
thinking of the water keeper
well keeper's been around a long time
the
um basically you have to watch it
because when you're talking about
probiotics and kefir
a lot of times they will put soy
in there like tofu kind of thing and so
you really have to watch it
and read labels six times and make sure
that there's no
gluten in there of any way shape or form
and so i i you know that's why we came
out with all of our
um we have all these
uh healthy um yeah we have a great
great line of probiotics dr well yeah i
mean we've got the microbiome
we have the nightly essence we have
um flora fx
yeah and floor effects is a great one
floor effects is a great one
yeah i absolutely love them
absolutely love them well let's go ahead
and go to our break we are going to take
five
minutes here on the astock live i would
like to encourage
all of you to get up and stretch move
your bodies get some blood flowing
through
and we will be back in about five
minutes
and again if anybody invited you to this
program
get back with the person that invited
you to this program
and thank them for giving you the
opportunity to ask dr wallach
specifically about your own health
concerns or
you know the fact that you were able to
listen in and hear what dr wallach is
saying
about other health concerns that may be
affecting you
so we will be right back don't go
anywhere
because we have another hour of ask doc
live coming right up
so
all right thank you everybody for
sticking around with
us during that short break again i hope
you got up
and stretched and got some other fluids
moving through your body
filled up your glass because you want to
make sure that you are staying hydrated
especially when we are in the summer
months for those of you who are in the
states i know in other places of the
world you are in a different season
but i love the fact that we are able to
come together
all in one place and get information
that we need to help us live
optimal lives now if you
have never ordered before and you are
interested
in getting information about what's
going to be best for you
and you'd like to place an order we do
have a call team that is standing by
at
three four 855-949-7234 again that's if
you have
never ordered longevity products before
but most importantly
you have not spoken to anybody
about the youngevity products if you
were sent here
to check out this program by somebody
specific you need to get back with them
don't call the call
team get back with the person that
invited you to this
program now for those of you who are
really
interested and wanting to know all
about dr wallick's research
about the products about how you can
help yourself
and your community we do have a
certified holistic health
coach program that is available not
specifically through critical health
news or longevity
but we have a program that's available
through the institute of holistic health
that will help you learn what you need
to
whether you want to use it just to help
yourself or you
want to make a business of it the
program also
teaches that you can find more
information about that
by calling our specialists at eight five
five
nine four nine 949-3377
again that is for information about our
certified holistic health coach program
so let's go ahead and
we are going to be getting back here
with dr
wallach dr wallach go ahead and unmute
yourself are you ready to keep going
let's go all right well let's go to our
next
hand up and our next hand
is david and again i want to remind
everybody
if you have a camera and you're able to
bring up your camera
your picture is worth a thousand words
for dr wallach
in making sure that he's giving you the
information you need as well
in addition to your answers to his
questions so
david you are on live with dr wallach
uh hi dr wallach hi david how can we
help you
hey uh i've got a couple questions here
my sister has thrombocytosis
um her platelet count is recently up to
000 and
[Music]
she was on hydroxyurea but death started
to
fail and uh she's now
uh just started taking jacoby
okay stop there how old is she
51 years old i'm sorry i missed you
i only got half the number say again 51
years old
i'm still not getting it i'm still not
getting the first number
61. okay six okay 61
okay she's five five
okay 107 pounds
okay does she have any other issues
other than high platelets does she have
high blood pressure diabetes kidney
issues is she on dialysis
no the only thing she has is the
platelet
disorder uh it had been up to over a
million about
a year and a half two years ago
okay okay i want to stop you there i
would bet that she she has other issues
does she have any bowel problems you
know any irritable bowel syndrome or
constipation diarrhea anything like that
no does she have gray or white or silver
hair
she sure does okay does she have any
varicose veins that she complains about
no okay does have any bowel problems any
constipation diarrhea
ibs not not very often
um she pretty much tells me give me a
full report every day on her condition
we live in it live together so i'm okay
does she
does she ever complain about anemia do
they ever say she's also anemic
yes that's yes absolutely okay i already
know what her problem is
okay all right um she has
bone marrow dysplasia did they ever tell
her that
uh i don't i do not believe so okay yeah
she got bone marrow dysplasia
which is kind of like osteoporosis of
the bone marrow
and does she have any ring in her ears
or balance problems or
pain in her arms and neck and hands uh
she sure does
until recently with hydroxyurea she had
a lot of leg pain
bone pain okay peripheral neuropathy and
osteoporosis of the skull yeah uh yes
okay and so yeah so it's more than just
high platelets is what i'm getting at
here
high platelets is a symptom of something
else so she's got
bone marrow dysplasia and did she ever
go to the doctor and get iron shots or
b12 shots or anything like that
um she got iron mm-hmm
okay yeah okay yeah her
what should i say i have to bite my
tongue here um
yeah this is she's got bone marrow
dysplasia and
um you know the next step these doctors
say you know you need a bone marrow
transplant
and it's gonna cost a hundred thousand
dollars but don't worry about it
insurance will pay for most of it
and uh this is really really a sad thing
because this is not aging
it's not autoimmune it's not anything
like that this is a simple nutritional
deficiency disease
always secondary to chronic gluten
issues
all right so she's got to get rid of all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat bread ryan nose no sugar
no carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go and
107 pounds i want her to have one
healthy brain and heart pack per month
get another bottle of arsenium not from
walgreens but arsenic because i got
those five cofactors in there because i
wanted to have six
of these selenium a day um three twice a
day or two three times a day whatever's
easier for her
and then i also want her to have our msm
i want her to get two bottles of msm
she can take three with each meal three
with each meal they're gonna support and
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone rings
bone itself
and she also needs two bowels of
immortalium which will stimulate the
bone route to make more
red blood cells and make more
antibodies and that kind of stuff more
white blood cells
and so i want her to have the mrtal in
two miles a month so you take three of
those twice a day
and let's see here um
i also wanted to have the vitamin d3
take three of those twice a day there's
two bottles a month
and i think let's start there
oh one other thing i do wanted to have
the few quiet sea capsules that's our
seaweed from an ocean eight or nine
different seaweeds in there and
take three of those capsules twice a day
that's gonna support our immune system
but also
is a particular stimulant for bone
marrow to make healthy red blood cells
and white blood cells and so forth
so she's got a lot more going on than
just too many uh too many platelets
right okay second question
second question for me is um i am
scheduled to get a
hip replacement on my my right hip
and it's been bothering me for quite a
while
and uh so far it looks like the femoral
head has been flattened
according to the x-ray and the mri
and uh okay i do have some neuropathy in
the
in my finger okay so
neuropathy okay
and um okay
high blood pressure do you have any gray
hair yes
okay how old are you what do you weigh
uh 165 i weigh 192 pounds
65 192.
oh five yeah
you're right okay do you have any other
issues any skin problems any bowel
problems
no any varicose veins
um i've noticed on my both of my knees
i'm seeing a little bit of
varicose veins starting i mean i've
never had them before
okay well to see they're not a genetic
thing they're not an age thing they're a
nutritional deficiency thing
so um do you have any do you have any
bowel problems any irritable bowel
syndrome
crohn's disease celiac disease
diverticulitis anything like that
uh no i don't do you have any history of
hiccups
no hiccups okay do you have anything
going on with your heart tachycardia
atrial fibrillation anything like that
uh no um just simply the high blood
pressure
okay okay all right well here we go
again you need to get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
also gluten so we brought it right now
so sugar
no carbohydrate drinks even the diet
one's got to go 192 pounds i want you to
have two healthy brain and heart packs a
month to full dose everything twice a
day
and then i want you to get um two
bottles of msm so you can take three
with each meal
and that's going to support and promote
mainstream pair of cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
the vertebrae bone makes your bone
itself
and then i also i want you to take our
um ultimate daily classic tail let's
take three of those twice today there's
two vowels a month and they will support
healthy
uh blood pressure and healthy blood flow
through blocked arteries
and your varicose veins will go away
your gray hair will go away
these things will actually help you
rebuild connective tissue in the walls
your arteries your veins
muscles uh also the head of the femur
um as long as there's
circulation which they did they tell you
there's still circulation to the head of
the femur
uh they are telling me that it might be
uh some necrosis in there
okay so we'll see because if there's
still some circulation to that head of
that femur
um we can rebuild it and so
um so i you know i would just give a
little bit of time
uh give it a month or so before you
decide on any surgery
okay
okay but you got to jump on this you can
start the diet immediately when you hang
up
and the ultimate daily that you just
mentioned again oh no oh no ultimate
daily
classic classic got it
and now that that will support healthy
blood pressure and healthy blood flow
for black parties do you have any kidney
issues that you know of
not that i know of sir okay well it
wouldn't hurt
you know you can test yourself you just
go to the pharmacy on a prescription get
some test strips for
urine tests and you know give you some
clue what's going on
um with your kidneys okay i think that
they're like a buck 50 each
you can afford it got it
okay and let's hear from you let's hear
from you on yourself and your sister
okay
i i sure will thank you so much doctor
okay god bless you sir
thank you all right thank you bye-bye
david i appreciate
dr you yvonne wrote in the comments that
she has bone
marrow dysplasia she's been following
your protocol for 12 months and her
numbers have been
steadily improving so isn't that
beautiful
beautiful beautiful beautiful beautiful
absolutely thank you yvonne
yeah now we do this thousands of times a
month all over the world
now dr welcome just before the break you
had mentioned we were going to be
talking about
muscular dystrophy gonna also talk about
multiple sclerosis and i would like to
bring our co-host
ruth ellen sanchez on to go ahead and
discuss
those conditions with you so
hello dr wallach yes ruth ellen
okay so i have um several clients
that have um multiple sclerosis
and one that has multi uh
muscular dystrophy sorry um
can you talk about what's the difference
between the two
and how you would go about helping a
person with
those conditions okay well just briefly
on the front end
multiple sclerosis is a brain
degenerative disease and musculosphere
is a nutritional deficiency
of the musculoskeletal system it could
be in an embryo it could be
you know you could be 50 years old and
get it okay then they start talking
about fibromyalgia when you're 50 years
old and you get it but when you're born
with it they call it muscular history
it's all just nutritional deficiencies
it's not genetic in any way shape or
form
um and of course just before we went to
the break we talked about
this marvin robin are giving i don't
know about a dozen
charts from kids um in um
utah indiana and eastern canada that we
had
actually reversed their muscusvien um
and the oldest one was i think 31.
they've been born with it and just
getting worse and worse was 31 years old
and you know in a year's time was gone
and so we gave jerry lewis a dozen of
those charts
and he was so excited he called the
doctors who had signed off on the charts
saying that we don't know why but these
kids don't have much discipline anymore
because of course the medical system
believes that it's a genetic disease
and um in animals it's called white
muscle disease and
every farmer without even a high school
education knows what to do to go to the
farm store and get the injections for a
calf
or lamb with white muscle diseases
most physically in humans but it's easy
to get rid of easy to prevent
mass multiple sclerosis is a
developmental thing of the brain
and usually people are born with it ms
multiple sclerosis
but it's not a genetic thing it's not an
autoimmune thing it's just mama's
deficient stuff
when the brain is developing and so they
have a whole variety of symptoms they
can go along with it and oftentimes
it's a fallback diagnosis when doctors
can't give a specific
diagnosis or something say well you have
ms you have multiple sclerosis because
it covers a lot of territory
it'd be balanced problems strength
problem um
memory problems it can go with vision
um it goes with
inability to deal with complex things
and so on
and so um with ms they need to be eating
three eggs twice a day
because 17 no let me back up 75
of your brain weight is cholesterol 75
of your brain weight is cholesterol
so you people with ms for sure need to
be eating three eggs twice
i'd do it three eggs twice a day uh soft
yolks
hardball days don't count and fridays
cause cancer so they want to be soft
boiled
soft poached soft soft scrambling butter
because you want that cholesterol to
rebuild the white matter of the brain
and then um they also want to one
healthy brain and heart pack for 100
pounds of body weight
they also want the um let's see here
i would i would go with the synaptive
through those twice a day
uh synaptive is the raw materials for
your brain cells to make the chemistry
that they need to talk to each other
and then also memory effects wouldn't
hurt to take through those twice a day
and uh you'll see here de-stress
capsules take three of those twice a day
although niacin plus take one
twice a day of that one and i think
that's where we want to go
uh for the ms thing and you'll be amazed
but
in both of these cases muscular
dystrophy and ms no gluten no wheat no
brother i know no fried foods no
processes meats no oils
all that's got to go but both of them
are totally preventable
musculosphere is totally reversible at
any age and
ms we can improve it significantly but
it depends on the percentage of damage
to the brain
and so we'd have to read the charts and
get more information and see what the
doctor
says and so on but you know we can
improve it 10
25 percent 50 but i've never seen
anybody cured of ms but i see it but
it's totally 100 percent preventable
if the mother is taking the 90th century
nutrients and eating her eggs and all
that kind of stuff
say for at least um three months before
she gets pregnant
taking pre yeah yeah taking prenatal
vitamins
when you're two months into your
pregnancy is not very wise
too late correct um i do have
a young lady who is getting prepared to
um get pregnant
and she's on the 90 and um got prenatal
vitamins from her doctor so she can
start preparing
and i told her to take both prenatal and
the 90.
correct she had a question because she
suffers from um
a mood disorder and she wanted to know
if she can take
de-stress while she's pregnant
oh absolutely each house is very good um
de-stress
you know she could take three of those
twice a day and um
also uh she's against away from all the
bad foods
but to de-stress it wouldn't hurt for
her also to take the ultimate niacin
plus she take one of those twice a day
and um let's see here
let's start there but she needs to come
on so i can ask her some questions
okay all right thank you dr molly okay
well thank you
back to you rebecca thank you ruth ellen
great
questions i i love the fact that we get
a little bit of description of what the
conditions
are as well and
what we can do to help to
prevent for future generations and also
what we can do as a reactive measure now
so dr weilik thank you so much for that
there's one more thing on that mushroom
history again the must first be
foundation or not foundation most
chesapeake association
fired jerry lewis and stop the telethon
when he brought them those charts
because those doctors felt they still
believe
that musculus was a genetic thing just
like they fired me from yerkes when i
said
cystic fibrosis wasn't genetic we
thought well jerry lewis i mean he's got
the power so rather than me say
something we gave him all the charts and
he took it to him and they fired jerry
lewis
that's how crazy these people are um you
know they should say you know we really
don't believe it just like these um
chefs they say okay well we don't
believe that gluten is bad and all this
kind of stuff
and so let's let's have a study here so
we did it for three years and so
what the musculus association should
have done says okay this is too wild you
know
we really just can't buy that without
looking at it so let's let's spend a
little time here and do some research
and see
if wallex observations are correct okay
that's what they should have done
fire jerry lewis after he raised two
billion dollars to find the cure
when he brings them the cure they fire
him that's why you don't hear anything
about the mustachy association anymore
well dr wellick your your research and
your approach
is disrupting agendas and
it's well it's in the smithsonian
institute is a national treasure my
thesis
5 000 pages and 20 000 autopsies is in
the smithsonian institute's national
treasure i'm very proud of that
so they need to ask your doctor do you
have a thesis in the smithsonian
institute like dr wallach
as a national treasure yeah
where's the credibility no i love the
fact that you have it dr welling
so um in regards to the cookbook
so there are several recipes and this is
pamela in the in the comments there's
several recipes with tomatoes
if one has art arthritis and has been
told to stay away from nightshades
what is dr wallach's suggestion to
substitute
for tomatoes and bell peppers
well um let's see here after you're on
our program
for a couple of months you can add a
little piece of tomato a little piece of
bell pepper
so you had to appreciate they weren't
trying to
cure arthritis by taking
off of tomatoes and bell peppers they
want to relieve symptoms and
manage it okay maintain it so you have
to come in every month or something
but once you get rid of your
arthritis you can eat all the tomatoes
and bell peppers you want
has nothing to do with the cause it's
just it could be an anti-inflammatory
thing
um and it may be the salad dressings
you're putting on there you know who
knows
it's one of those things where um once
you're on the nutritional program you're
off all the bad stuff
um you know give a little shot you take
a little thin slice of a tomato or take
a couple of strips of a bell pepper and
see if you get any negative reaction
all right thank you for that and monica
is asking the question can i skip a meal
and just take 90 minerals with large
amounts of vitamins
i'm a vegan and it's hard to find what
to eat
okay well what i recommend this is
monica right
yes okay what i recommend is you become
an
an ovo lacto pisco vegan
hobo meaning eggs you take that little
white dot off the yolk when you see a
you know crack of raw egg there's that
little white dot on top of the yolk
that's the chicken
everything else inside the egg is just
raw materials
it's not an animal the animals in that
little white dot take that off
prey on it bury them or flush them down
the toilet bury them at sea
and they can softball or soft scramble
to poach those eggs because they want
all that cholesterol and stuff
being vegan you're going to wind up with
all kinds of brain problems including
alzheimer's disease
okay then lacto is milk what's the first
rebecca what's the first diet that all
mammals get whether a whale are
a rhinoceros or hippopotamus or a
gorilla or a human being
a monkey a horse um any
mammal what's her first food well in
most cases it's mother's milk
milk uh so milk is not bad and so that's
kind of an insane
approach and then
pisco is fish and so there's no red meat
and fish
and so you want to be an ovo lacto pisco
vegetarian and take the 90 cents
nutrients you'll add 25 to 50 healthy
years your life
if you just want to live on tomatoes and
bell peppers and beans and squash
you're in trouble i
i know i couldn't do it and so
the next question is how about avocados
are avocados okay to eat dr molly
well avocado is a very interesting fruit
and you know if you take it and you
from the grocery store and you peel it
and slice it and eat it that's fine
but i wouldn't keep it in your house for
a week and then eat it because the oils
in the avocado oxidize and turn into
trans fats and have psychic means
acrylamides
and can be a negative you certainly
don't want to heat them
you can you know make take and put raw
slices in a salad or something like that
or have it as a fruit for breakfast but
uh you know don't be heating it
and don't you know keep the avocados in
your cupboard
for a week and then use them because
then you know the fats
and oils inside the avocado are oxidized
yeah i don't know how anybody could eat
it an oxidized avocado
i love avocado and i'll take two
avocados and i'll smash them up i'll put
some of our guacamole mix from our
savory
blend in there and some himalayan salt
and that will be a meal for me i
absolutely love it
and you're getting the good fats yeah
you're getting good fats you're getting
fiber and you're getting you know
some other vitamins and things just from
the flesh of the avocado
awesome so one of our watchers today dr
wallach would like to know about breast
cancer
she has a possible diagnosis and had a
biopsy
done yesterday
okay all cancers are preventable they're
not genetic
they're not autoimmune they're based on
what you eat what you don't eat
what things you come in contact with
what things you do not come in contact
with
so that's why we stress so much about
staying away from all the bad foods
so you can reduce all this inflammation
also to reduce your risk of cancer you
want to be taking antioxidants and
support your immune system
so if you have a history in your family
it's not a genetic thing but if you have
a history in your family you're going to
eat the same way your families you live
in the same area your family's living in
um i'll get a hair now let's just get
our book
rare urban cures go to i think it's
chapter 10 or 11 and teach you how to
collect the hair where to ship it
you should put be sure to put the check
in there with it because it won't the
lab won't run the test without the check
and they'll send it back to you and
there's two charts in there one is
the levels of the essential nutrients
essential minerals
and if they're all below the bottom line
that means oh you're not absorbing
that's very useful information
uh if they're all scattered all over the
place that's what's supposed to be
um and if they're below a certain line
you need to be really seriously
supplementing well why not supplement
with them all
but then of course you people always say
to me well i'm sure
i've got some toxic metals well why
while i was in the military 25 years ago
or i worked in this factory or i lived
in a big city
did you ever have a hair analysis no did
the doctor do any blood tests for
heavy metals no well in this hair
analysis there's another chart
that goes into lead mercury
um all kinds of
other metals that people are concerned
about
and so it's worth it i get a hair
analysis
once a year because i travel so much i'm
on airplanes and
buses and trains and all kinds of stuff
drive with people long distances
give talks in various factories and
things so who knows
what you get and so i've been you know
doing uh hair analysis every year so i'm
keeping track of what i have what i
don't have
and you know because i've been taking
all these nutrients for so long
i just don't accumulate the bad um
metals
because even uranium uh
you know i was in the military for 27
years who knows how much exposure i had
to those kind of things
but um i just don't have that stuff
because i'm taking all these nutrients
which help your body dump them which
helps your body dump them
so i'm fascinated by the hair analysis
dr wallach
and in this analysis report it also
talks about the ratios
yeah different different minerals in in
comparison to
others share with us a little bit about
the importance of those ratios
well for instance if you have
the ratio out of balance between
phosphorus and
calcium you can take minerals out of
your bones
you don't want more phosphorus than
calcium you want more calcium than
phosphorus
and it depends on your diet and if
you're supplementing you're not where
you live where the water source is all
those kind of things
um play a part in how much nutrients
you're getting
and i'm actually coming out with a big
paper on that subject
um probably by the end of this month and
it's being copy written
before i say anything about it because
you know they fired me for saying
something once
i was i was correct but they fired me
away from your keys um they fired jerry
lewis
we were correct but they fired jerry
lewis because again the doctors wouldn't
believe that
most physician was a just a simple
nutritional efficiency
and so i can't fire myself i'm not
worried about that but i'm worried about
some
um reporters or some of the people they
might show it to to get their opinion on
it
and they'll say oh my god this is the
answer and they'll take it and claim it
themselves so i got to get a copy
written before i say anything about it
well i'm not going to fire you either
yourself
so um thank you everybody again for
being here with us with ask doc
live dr wallach is sharing a wealth of
information
and i know that he speaks fast that's
why we
we have the replays of our programs
posted on the askdoclive.com
website so you can go back and listen to
them
again and share them with others as
you're listening through
you're going to be thinking of oh this
person has that and this
person has that please share these
videos let's get this knowledge
out there so that we can really make a
positive
impact on our world okay rebecca
let's go let's go let's go back to this
res cache i want to put two more
sentences on this here
okay um okay um just to
do a basic thing she's got here with all
the bad foods no matter if it's just
inflammation or if it's cancer or
whatever it is she's got something going
on which is a negative here
uh concerns the doctors of course and so
none of the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils and gluten so
wheat bread right now so sugar no
carbonated drinks
and then per 100 pounds of body weight i
wanted to have one healthy brain and
heart pack per month
if she only weighs 120 130 i wanted to
get another bottle of water slim with
the five cofactors in it so you take
three of those twice a day
i also want her to take our killer
biotic
not only does it help your immune system
against the covid virus but it also
helps
your immune system against all kinds of
stuff including cancer and so forth
and we can't make any claims about how
well it works
but it's a bunch of mushrooms to support
your immune system
and then of course uh you want to be
taking
everything you can we have oxy body
oxygen um
is it is one of the enemies of cancer
and so
per 100 pounds of body weight never take
an ounce of our oxy body a day
it'd be a half ounce twice a day one
quart per month
and so let's start by doing those things
and that way she's going to get a head
start here because it's going to take
two or three days or maybe a week to get
the answer back there but she can start
on the diet today
and then um depending where she lives
and if she lives close to a warehouse
she's going to
run go pick it up today if it's going to
be shipped to her it might be three days
or five days based on where she lives
and so um but she needs to get on these
things asap
and of course the doctors if it is
cancer they're going to give her a list
of their options
and say there's here's 10 things we want
to give you these three
okay well oh one other thing i do wanted
to take
is the btt 2.0 tablets now the bt
that's in addition to the btt 2.0 powder
which is the vitamins and minerals that
comes with the healthy brain heart pack
for the btt 2.0 tablets they support the
immune system
and also our anti-inflammatory i wanted
to take three of those twice two days
would be one bottle a month there
all right thank you dr wallach for
finishing that up i appreciate that and
i know she does as well
let's go to our next hand up with our
live
audience here and that is maggie maggie
go ahead and unmute yourself
you were on live with dr wallach
hi maggie
i sent you a request all you have to do
is say okay
and it should unmute you
oh let's try again that turns your video
[Music]
off
no you're still not unmuted yet
you see at the bottom do you see the
little microphone it has a red line
through it you want to touch that
and unmute
ah it's not unmuting all right well
let's go to
our next live hand that is up and that
is
arlene sorry maggie
arlene so
you're on live with dr wallach hi how
are you thank you for taking my call
um i have two quick questions one is
about my cat
uh he has a cyst um it's about an inch
long
um it's very red i took them to the vet
and that took a um biopsy does it i
haven't had the results back yet if it's
malignant or not is there anything i can
do
well um first of all how much does a cat
weigh
15 pounds 16 big big guy so it must be a
male big guy
now yeah so 16 pounds i wanted to have
one scoop of our arts for decks which is
our
heavy duty vitamin minerals for dogs and
cats that's one scoop for 20 pounds of
body weight so
i would add to its food the um
one scoop of the arthur dex i would also
give it
uh one of our efa pluses which come it's
essential fatty acids
which goes uh which comes from actually
fish
and cats like that and then again i
would also give it the
killer biotic which has mushrooms in it
and so just i think i would go ahead and
open two of those capsules and put that
powder
in with the food and then let's see what
the biopsy says before we do anything
else
okay okay thank you and the other
question i have is about myself
um i do have varicose veins
behind my knees but now i'm noticing
that they're actually coming up
into my thigh and the other problem i
have is in the morning
when i wake up my fingers are very very
stiff and so are my toes and i actually
have to move
you know around quite a while before
like you know the pain subsides
yeah so you have peripheral neuropathy
do you have a back problem
uh sometimes i have lower back pain but
also my neck's been bothering me a lot
too when i wake up in the morning
okay do you have any ringing in your
ears any tinnitus ring in your ears
no was that a no
no okay do you have any hiccups
no do you have any balance problems
maybe a little bit okay so
all right yeah uh how old are you what
do you weigh 62
and i'm 115 pounds okay
yeah you have osteoporosis call you have
some low back issues and neck
issues um the neck issues could be just
degenerative disc disease but it can
also be the osteoporosis of the skull
squeezing the spinal cord
and the low back stuff doing all the
stuff in the feet and the toes
so um 115 pounds absolutely
no none of the bad foods no fried foods
no processed meats no oils no gluten so
we've no brown rhinos no sugar
no carbonated drinks um even the diet
one's got to go
and then 115 pounds of heavy take one
healthy brain and heart pepper a month
get another bottle of water sleeping
with the five cofactors and take three
twice a day or two three times a day for
a total of six a day
i also um want you to take our
glucogel if you prefer the liquid you
could take a half ounce twice a day one
quart per month if you prefer the
capsules
you take three twice a day to be one
bottle a month it's a big bottle
and that'll help regrow cartilage and
ligaments and tendons and connective
tissue the disc between the vertebrae
and the skull and everything else
um let's see here uh
if i didn't say it vitamin d3 three of
those twice a day there's two bowels a
month
and uh let's go there
okay thank you very much dr wallace i
appreciate your work
well you're very welcome arlene thank
you thank you bless you
and arlene also had a question in
regards to what is the difference
between two types of
arthritis the rheumatoid arthritis and
osteoarthritis dr wallach
well kill osteoarthritis is a
nutritional deficiency it could be just
a straight nutritional deficiency
and it can be and or a nutritional
deficiency
caused by not supplementing with the
nutrients but also a gluten issue so
even if you're
absorbing you have to get rid of gluten
and then
when you have rheumatoid arthritis r.a
that is the nutritional deficiency
arthritis with a secondary infection
with a bug called mycoplasma
which causes a rheumatoid arthritis
factor
and doctors once you believe it's an
autoimmune disease your body's attacking
itself no there's
actually an antibody called menocycline
like the bait fish mino menocycline
she needs a six to eight week
dose of mental cycling along with the
the healthy brain and heart pack and the
msm and
glucogel and vitamin d3 and all that
kind of stuff and even rheumatoid
arthritis i'm sure if you've had
rheumatoid arthritis for 40 years
usually within 60 90 days it's gone
all right thank you so much dr wellick
let's go ahead and move on to our next
hand that is up and that is dixie
dixie go ahead and unmute yourself
you are on live with dr wallach hi dixie
hi doctor how you doing
okay how can we help you uh i'm
61 years old i weigh 188 pounds
i'm five foot five and a half well five
five now i've lost
almost an inch um
i had hep c and i went on the
riboviron interferon six months
then i was off nine months and then they
put me back on it for 11 months
and i'm viral
i sustained a response so i don't have
hep c
and but six months after the last
treatment
i woke up and i felt like i sucked on a
salt lick all night long
and since then i've had systemic
inflammation um
i'm hypothyroid i still have thyroid
symptoms
i'm still losing hair
uh what else are you coloring so much
are you coloring your hair do you have
gray hair no my hair
it's going gray okay
okay and then do you have varicose veins
i have spider veins that counts yes
thank you
i've also been told i'm insulin
okay so do you have diabetes or
pre-diabetes
i was told i had insulin resistance
so that means you have pre-diabetes or
diabetes
do they put you on medication yeah
so you're taking insulin okay so you're
not taking any medication for that
okay here we go nothing okay you need to
give it all the bad foods no fried foods
no processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat bread right now sugar
and no cruciferous vegetables because
you have a history of thyroid dish no
cruciferous vegetables no
cabbage broccoli cauliflower brown
sprouts or kale and then
i want you to take two healthy brain and
heart packs per month two healthy brain
hard packs per month the full dose
everything twice a day
i want you to take our oceans gold take
three of those twice a day
our fucoid z take three of those twice
today both are for the thyroid
and then because of the hep c thing and
susceptibility to viruses with all this
um stuff going on here with the covid i
would go ahead
and get um our colloidal silver take uh
two droppers full under your tongue 30
minutes for each meal and 30 minutes for
a bedtime and it's going to take you
two of these four ounce bottles a month
to pull this off
i've been doing it for 25 years okay
um don't forget our hand sanitizer i
also
want you to take our killer biotic go
ahead and take three of those twice a
day with those mushrooms and support
your immune system
i would also take the um btt 2.0 tablets
take three of those twice a day that
says um i think it's a big enough body
to be able to do that
with one bottle um and i think that's
going to cover this
uh let's see here and uh five foot five
i'd like to see away 140 150 so you
might need to lose 40 pounds
but just getting off the bad foods
you're going to lose 15 20 pounds
without trying
if you want to go faster with that's a
problem
since the treatment for my liver
i it's almost impossible for me to lose
weight no matter what i try
okay
if you're not eating fried foods you're
not eating gluten you're going to lose
weight
okay you got to give up the gluten
there are no such things as gluten-free
oats
it has gliadin in them i've gone gluten
dairy
soy sugar-free okay
good now i also again
uh want you to take um
oh let's see here talk about killer
biotic take three of those twice a day
as well as mushrooms in there oh yeah
now if you want to lose
this weight um faster than a half a
pound a day
we have a keto bar uh there's 10 in a
box you're going to need to get three
boxes so be one bar
a day for a month and uh
it doesn't have to be the same meal it
could be breakfast for two days a week
and lunch for
three days a week and so on it doesn't
matter and then after two months
go to two meals a day uh with the keto
bar
um for two meals out of the week and the
other five days stay on one
okay and you'll you'll you'll lose a
half a pound of two pounds a day very
quickly
and so let's go there so you're gonna
all these things
you're covering a lot of territory but
all these things you have
none of them are genetic mm-hmm none of
my autoimmune they're all things you can
prevent and reverse very
quickly okay okay
what do i do about food sensitivities
well there's options okay uh for
instance what food sensitivities do you
have
almost what don't i have um
okay stop okay you may be allergic to
um cow dairy
cow milk but you could eat sheep milk or
goat milk
or llama milk okay and people say well
i'm allergic to eggs what about duck
eggs
or emu eggs or turkey eggs or pigeon
okay and so it's one of those
things where you have to find out which
one you can have and
invariably when you have a gluten
problem that causes you to have
reactions to food
and doctors just you know wipe it off
and say oh you got an allergy to stay
away from that
you can't just live on tofu
even even tofu you got to read the
label and it's got to say certified
gluten-free because guess what they mix
with the soy to make tofu
wheat flour so if so if you're eating
tofu you're getting a lot of gluten
okay good but you have to read labels it
has got to say
i like to see the gluten-free label on
it and it also says gluten-free
underneath the gluten-free label
and so that way you know you're
reasonably assured
that you're going to be gluten-free
because um
you have you can't even absorb oral
medication you can't absorb oral
medication
if you're eating gluten because your
intestines won't absorb medication won't
absorb nutrition
and that's why people are a mess and he
said well i'm a mess
you know my bad genes i got this and
that no
let's get off the gluten take the 90 and
let's see what happens here
uh what if we're what if we only get rid
of eight of your ten diseases that's not
bad
i'd like to get rid of them all
autoimmunity sucks
okay well you don't have any autoimmune
diseases are not that's why my thesis is
in the smithsonian institute as a
national treasure there are no genetic
diseases there are no autoimmune
diseases
my 5 000 page thesis 20 000 autopsies is
in the smithsonian institute as a
natural treasure
i'm one of the fathers i'm one of the
two founding fathers of the science of
epigenetics
which take the place of genetics and
autoimmune
lupus isn't autoimmune this is a simple
nutritional deficiency disease
okay psoriatic arthritis is not
autoimmune it's a simple nutritional
deficiency
but doctors don't know anything about
that how do i heal a leaky gut
oh that's easy leaky gut is a gluten
issue
okay that's another name for irritable
bowel syndrome
so what you want to do is stay away from
gluten no wheat nobody around
doctor i have okay
uh let's bet let's bet a dinner in paris
you want to buy my ticket no
i eat i don't
buy i i cook all my own food i grow my
own vegetables
i don't care i don't know what more to
do if you're growing your own vegetables
and eating them and you you can't there
is no such thing as gluten-free bread
there's no such thing as gluten-free
crackers there is no such thing as
gluten-free oats
business as gluten-free cereal and
dewy tortillas no
well there you go do you cook for him i
have to
gluten alert gluten alert gluten alert
gluten alert
you're getting cross-contaminated kick
him out of the house or make him eat
like you
i knew you had a you had it somewhere
yeah you're getting cross-contaminated
your house is full of gluten
how does that happen you ever hear a
dust
yeah okay here do you wash your clothes
with his clothes
yeah you sleep do you sleep with him no
he snores you ever hug him and kiss him
of course well there you go his saliva
is full of gluten
his sweat is full of gluten do you wash
his clothes
yeah well there you go i mean he's full
of it and you're cause containing
yourself that's the problem
okay so you only you owe me the dinner
in paris
can i take a rain check on that
[Laughter]
okay all right okay rebecca how are you
doing here
dixie that's what it is
all right so dr welling next question is
is there anything that can remove
calcium deposits in the veins
of course um
calcium deposits are usually not in the
veins they're usually in arteries
okay and so again they need to get all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meat no oils no glutens that
we brought rhinos or sugar
they need to take one healthy brain
heart pack for 100 pounds of body weight
you need to take
three of the ultimate daily classic
tablets twice a day for a hundred pounds
of body weight
and they need to stay away from salad
dressings that have oils in them they
need to go to our savory division and
get our things you know like
apple cider vinegar salad dressing and
that kind of stuff
and eat properly and supplement properly
and take the ultimate daily classic
tablets three twice a day per hundred
pounds of body weight
and the the plaque and arteries goes
away
but you can't have fried food cannot
have fried foods cannot have anything
that oxidizes
because that's what causes plaque in the
arteries not cholesterol
cholesterol is innocent do not take
statin drugs
if you have any statin drugs at home box
them up and give them to your doctor
with love don't waste them come to your
doctor
we need cholesterol for a healthy brain
that's right 75
of your brain weight is cholesterol 95
of the
weight of estrogen and progesterone is
cholesterol 95
of the weight of testosterone is
cholesterol and so
um yeah you're doing something this
person's doing something wrong when it
comes to
um uh sources of oxidation inflammatory
stuff and
oxidized oils and fried foods and that
kind of stuff
well my family ate fried foods for their
whole life and they lived to be
90. well did they have a wood stove oh
yeah
that's what grandma had was so well
she's putting wood ashes in her garden
do you put wood ashes in your food
no okay
here's the difference there's a there's
a big difference but we do want to
remind people
food back then and food now are totally
different
where the food now especially if you're
buying it and it's already prepared it's
in a box
it is it's void of the nutrients that
your body needs to be able to
even consider addressing all the things
that's coming at it
so we definitely recommend you not try
to out supplement before diet
your best option is to follow dr
wallick's good foods bad foods
as you mentioned and then the
supplementation just to make sure that
your body is getting
what it needs and that
please get the cookbook i'm mine should
be here any day
dr wallace cooking without the bad
foods see i got it right
i do know how to read i went to school
several years
um so yeah
it's we're coming up to the top of the
hour dr wallach and
i know we have lots of questions still
we have hands up
we got time for one more let's go ahead
and get one more
so susan has her hand up
susan go ahead and unmute yourself you
are on live with dr
wallach thank you very much dr wallace
i'm happily uh
hi i my my phone uh my
video went off let's try to get it back
on again it won't go on
okay no video i still agree here yeah
well i'm doing really well i'm i'm
calling because
i wanted to talk about one of the
customers i'm working with his name ken
six foot three 72 years old he had a
intestinal bypass he was 400 pounds and
when he took your products he's taking
14 of your products
including the btt 2.0
and all the others he's doing great he
lost
he's down to him he lost 50 pounds
and um but the problem he has is he's
been diagnosed
with severe emphystema and he did have
a gastric bypass um years ago
and he had pneumonia several times this
year but his problem is mucus
he says he just doesn't know what to do
about a large amount of mucus
that's coming up constantly is there
anything else he can do
besides all of the products he's taking
okay well if he doesn't have him in
there he needs a few quite
a capsule you take three three times a
day is three miles a month if you prefer
as a liquid you could take three quarts
a month take an ounce three times a day
okay and then uh of the z radical that's
the liquid form of the few coinci
and then i don't know if he's using the
keto bars
uh he could start out as one okay he can
start out with one keto bar
um a day that's be three boxes a month
because there's only ten bars in a box
doesn't have to be the same meal every
day and after two months he can go to
um two meals a day for two days out of
the week the other five days stay on one
meal a day
but he needs to eat like an asian eat
rice and sweet potatoes and beans and
squash
and when he's taken all these
supplements he shouldn't be hungry
that's why he lost 50 pounds because
when you're taking
nutrients you're not hungry your body's
not looking for stuff
people gain weight because they're
looking for stuff because
the one of the symptoms of nutritional
deficiencies is
pica p-i-c-a you can look it up in any
dictionary p-i-c-a
that behavior is your body drives you to
eat because it's looking for those
nutrients
if you're just eating calories you gain
weight if you take the supplements you
will lose weight because your body is
happy and won't eat as much
okay
those are the two things i would add
okay um
okay and and about the mucus he keeps
complaining to
to me about is there anything the doctor
can can help him with that
he's gone to his doctors about it and
all sorts of stuff and i don't know if
he's taking any medication
but um it just doesn't seem to end okay
well he needs to stay away from
from gluten no wheat butter and oats
okay okay
and um he needs to uh get on that fucoid
z
uh or the z radical which whichever one
he likes
that'll help there but he's got to save
it for many inflammatory things
he can't have one cheat meal per week
you cannot have one cheat meal per month
okay all right thank you thank you very
much dr wallace
okay thank you thank you thank you bye
dr welling i have a question in regards
to
the killer biotic um i
have people that have taken it has you
know when they've had lung infections
and it's just been fantastic they love
it
um but a question that i get is can they
continue to take it
or yeah it's something that they only
use for a short amount of time
i've been taking it three three of those
twice a day for 25 years
there you go so i didn't think that
there would be a problem you know as an
herbalist the herbs that are in there
are absolutely fantastic
with anti-viral anti-fungal antibiotics
we get those mushrooms from all over the
world yeah yeah so
amazing stuff in that killer biotic well
dr wellick we are at the top of the
hour i just want to thank you so much
for being here with us another full two
hours i want to thank my co-host jonty
mccollier
nassema omar rusell and sanchez for
all they do in the background and
keeping everything going
and running smoothly we greatly greatly
appreciate all of you
and most of all you that are listening
thank you so much for taking time
out of your day to empower yourself with
information that you will be able to use
to help yourself and those around you as
there is so much that we can do and
epigenetics has proven
that what we put into our bodies in the
environment that we are
in makes a world of difference on how
our health
is today and tomorrow so everybody
go to askdoclive.com you can get the
replays there
you'll have our store there you can get
dr wallick's books there
but again i don't wanna i don't know how
i can stress this a month
anymore if somebody shared this program
with you
get back with them they
truly think something of you and want to
make sure that you are getting what you
need so you can live your best
life as well so on behalf of myself or
rebecca kozak and our whole team
dr wallach we love you we love you too
thank you very much and
we will see you again next week same
place same time
absolutely bye bye
love you all right bye everybody
yes sema ruth ellen john t
love you guys bye bye